everyone's been saying hey Sam how's
that master class cuz I guess I'm the
only one here who showed up 90 bucks to
take Aaron Sorkin's writing master class
dammit how could this have happened
here's something important to remember
about dialog no one ever in life starts
a sentence with damnit it's funny
because my mom actually sent me a link
right before it came out oh this is
weird so I bought it and I didn't
realize is like does the day was
released so I got it I started going
through it and actually is like holy
crap this is really really in-depth and
even though it's got a 90 dollar price
tag once you break it down it's like 2
bucks per lesson obviously that's pretty
cool I'm really interested in writing
and everyone else here is I mean it's a
big part of what we do here every video
requires some sort of writing also we
are working on much larger project that
really requires serious writing so
understanding how writing works is
something that's just a constant
practice at night you know more but it
in your head then you're able to put on
on the piece of paper and so the first
thing that's why I'm but the first
question I'm asking you after we read
these things is did you understand what
what you just read that's always what I
want to know of when I'm done before we
get to is a good or bad this master
class goes through a lot of techniques
that is specifically Aaron Sorkin uses
so I've started this class for about a
week week and a half here and already
though it's pretty cool by the way this
is not sponsored distance that there's
no testimonial Aaron Sorkin is a very
prolific screenwriter the course starts
off with two things which are intention
and obstacles using those as a driving
core force in a story it might seem
obvious it's very easy to miss sometimes
when creating stories of your own
intention as then what is the character
trying to do accomplish so and so forth
what is driving them what internal force
in the character is bringing them seem
to seeing him and you know these things
don't need to be huge doesn't even each
plot points but their existence helps
just keep the ball rolling obstacles
pretty dang obvious things that you
wouldn't expect to go wrong going wrong
things getting in the way basically
things adding tension to that intention
this seems dead simple but most of all I
think that intention is very easy to
miss sometimes when thinking of a story
because very often you can get wrapped
up in a character or the back
or the background or the world or some
cool lasers or costumes and you know
just that's a simple drive that simple
scene-by-scene
really really helps
I don't wanna I don't wanna prod but
what happened house installing Mac Drive
to read that Mac formatted harddrive and
that I was like no no wow
so Nico you try to install a Mac Mac
Drive right they have an app or a
program that lets you read Macintosh
formatted drives on the PC so there's no
window or just as you need to buy a Mac
product in order to do this no what
about Mac hardware did you have to buy
my card where does that energy after
like send Mac a secret exclusivity code
I didn't have to do anything related to
Steve Jobs whatsoever really all I did
is this probably way crashed
alright Spencer's into the repair
console it's this is an Appalachian
dulcimer and I got it in Iceland and why
would I go to Iceland to buy an
Appalachian dulcimer which is
technically an American instrument well
you love music I do love music but the
thing is is that you know we go to we go
to Iceland and I am just looking at
stuff to do and if you know I was
thinking wait a second I love old
medieval folk music and a specifically
folk metal so I'm trying to find a food
like some sort of Icelandic folk
instrument and I found one called the
lines feel which is basically it looks
like a box with a couple strings tied to
the top of it it's not a very pretty
instrument but it's a traditional
Icelandic instrument and in doing
further research I realized wait a
second this lang spiel is actually it's
basically in this family of drone
zippers and dulcimers and stuff so
there's lots of similar some instruments
to it anyway so I go to Iceland I go to
this one a little music shop and I
talked to the guy say hey I'm looking
for a lang spiel and he's like bad news
then like what he's like well the guy in
Iceland who makes Lang spills died
recently and and I was like oh damn so
does that mean it's like well we can't
give it links people now because no
one's making them in more than
quantities of one and I'm like oh that
sucks and he's like ah don't worry
actually because they kind of sucked he
was just making him in his garage they
weren't that nice
here this is what you want and he shows
me this the Appalachian dulcimer he says
it's exactly the same same strings
tuning same everything it's just a
different shape but it's effectively the
exact same instrument in almost every
way other than superficially so I'm like
okay I'm sold and I got it and I started
playing it and I realize it was the
coolest instrument ever because you just
each time you strum a note you turn it
it turns into a medieval folk song so
it's like
anyway so it's whatever you know it's
fun to play play it on your lap I wish
you could play it like a guitar like
this he Spencer has a fear still broken
my brother even Peter makes me feel bad
you need to ask that question does
anyone understand okay let's see where
we got hung up
class PMP I did make it a little further
than just the first episode aaron sorkin
approaches characters a lot differently
than other writers and screenwriters and
that is to have an idea of the character
some sort of goal of what you want them
to be characters become defined and you
know you understand these characters
deeper as you go through scenes with
them and these decisions you choose for
those characters those decisions on the
page in the movie are the ones that
define the character is not the
biography that you wrote for the
character before I even started writing
like oh they got a blue pair of shoes
when they're nine they got into a fight
in a junior high school when they're 13
it's like all that stuff what does that
have to do for senior writing like
unless there is like an active moment
where they're like hey you're that
person who beat me up when I was 13 let
the characters develop as you write them
the idea in is that you have the better
understanding of the character after
you're finished writing your piece then
before you began is you don't want to
pigeonhole yourself in because the more
you start defining these characters and
the more of a biography you write for
them the less opportunity you have to
play with the character in that scene I
like that keeps things fluid keeps
things moving impulsive spontaneous and
more than anything else let's the
character you defined by the scenes that
they are in rather than the ones in
their backstory that we haven't seen yet
so there you go